Wie ist die Lage?
Auch vielleicht kurz vorm Bundeslockdown, oder? Das wird ja, ist auch so ein Hashtag, den ich bei Twitter jetzt häufig gesehen habe, Bundeslockdown. Übrigens auch von Luisa Neubauer wurde der verbreitet und das fand ich ganz amüsant, weil am gleichen Tag wurden Fotos veröffentlicht von Luisa Neubauer, ein Modeshooting hat sie gemacht mit anderen Damen zusammen in der Elbphilharmonie und man twittert dann zugleich Bundeslockdown. Also ich finde, da muss man sich ein bisschen entscheiden, was man machen will. Oder nimmt man sich einfach immer aus der Gleichung raus, dann kann ich es natürlich verstehen. Aber dann frage ich mich, bedeutet das auch Klimawandel für alle, nur nicht für mich?
Also ich habe die Markus Land Sendung von gestern noch nicht gesehen, aber es ist wohl das Zitat von Markus Söder überliefert, nachdem Laschet kam mit seinem Brücken-Lockdown. Ich habe diese These eigentlich, wenn ich das so sagen darf, immer vertreten, die Kanzlerin auch. Da habe ich da drunter getwittert, ja das ist wie damals bei Trump, als irgendwas waren auf Ruhe und dann schrieb Trump blablabla. Angela agrees. Also alle rangeln um Angela und wollen ihre Zustimmung. Und nachdem Laschet sehr gestriezt wurde bei Markus Söder hinsichtlich, sie standen immer an der Seite der Kanzlerin während der Flüchtlingsdebatte und jetzt wird ihnen der Platz gerauft von Markus Söder. Wie finden sie das? Und Laschet sagt nur, ist so. Und es wird wohl kolportiert, dass Laschet jetzt den Brücken-Lockdown nur wollte, um sich bei Merkel einzuschleichen. Meine These ist die von Matthias, der auch hier die Musik macht für diesen Podcast. Die Leute wollen einfach nur eine politische Entscheidung. Man will mal wieder, dass die Politik was entscheidet, was man dann auch wirklich als Effekt auf der Straße sieht.
Ja, aber ich glaube, dass das natürlich eine tolle Fantasie ist, zu sagen, das ist jetzt der allerletzte Lockdown. Der allerletzte Lockdown kann es ja nur sein, wenn man sagt, danach sind ja alle dann geimpft. Und das ist ja nicht der Fall. Jetzt dürfen die Hausärzte impfen. Aber auch das gestaltet sich schwierig, wenn sie nur ganz wenig Impfstoff zur Verfügung haben. Und wie jetzt im Falle von meinen Eltern, die haben es jetzt mit regelrechten Idioten als Hausärzte zu tun, die dann eine ganz merkwürdige Priorisierung vornehmen, beziehungsweise dann sagen, man ruft dort an, direkt an dem Tag, an dem es geht, will einen Termin machen, und dann sagen die Termine sind voll. Und dann sagt man, ja, das macht ja nichts, dann setzen sie mich doch einfach auf die Liste. Nee, wir haben uns jetzt überlegt, sie alle sollen einfach in 14 Tagen, wenn wieder neue Termine möglich sind, wieder um 8 Uhr anrufen und gucken, ob sie dran sind. Also so ein Spiel wird da nicht. Da muss man sagen, damit macht man die Leute Mürbe. Und ich fand das sehr schön, dass dann meine Mutter mich anrief und sagte, ob ich denn schon gesehen habe, dass es jetzt auch Influencer gibt. Und sie ist sehr sauer, dass sie jetzt überhaupt keine Chance hat, überhaupt einen Impftermin zu bekommen. Und zugleich gibt die Bundesregierung 25 Millionen für eine Influencer-Kampagne aus. Das heißt, da werden jetzt irgendwelche Stars vor die Kamera gezerrt, dass sie Werbung machen für Impfungen, wo ich sage, na ja, wer wirbt, hat es nötig, kann man in diesem Fall glaube ich wirklich einmal sagen. Außerdem, es braucht überhaupt nicht jetzt für Impfungen geworben zu werden. Die Leute wollen sich impfen lassen, haben aber nach wie vor keine Möglichkeit. Überhaupt das große Thema, das ja nach wie vor nicht so thematisiert wird, wie man es eigentlich müsste. Und was passiert jetzt? Also ich habe dann auch meiner Mutter gesagt, ja dann ruft doch das nächste Mal beim Arzt an und sagt, tach Herr Doktor, ich habe die Uschi-Glas gesehen im Fernsehen, die lässt sich impfen, ich will mich auch impfen lassen. Also auf solche Leute setzt man da und dann verlangen die Stars wohl kein Honorar. Da heißt es aber, sie bekommen eine Aufwandsentschädigung. Und ich möchte nicht wissen, wie diese Aufwandsentschädigung ist. Die wird ja vermutlich nicht bei 250 Euro liegen. Es ist ein so zum Himmel schreiender Skandal, zeigt aber auch nochmal, wie die Bundesrepublik denkt, wie alt sie denkt. Also jetzt muss man die Uschi-Glas nochmal herholen, um für Impfungen zu werben. Und es wird auch verkannt, dass Menschen soziale Wesen sind. Und das heißt, dass die Leute, die ein bisschen skeptisch gegenüber Impfungen sind, ich rede jetzt nicht von den vehementen Impfgegnern, die lassen sich ja auch von der Uschi nicht überreden, aber die so ein bisschen skeptisch ängstlich sind, ach soll ich jetzt, soll ich noch warten. Was machen die? Die unterhalten sich genau darüber mit ihren Verwandten und Freunden. Das ist nämlich genauso wie bei einer Hüft-OP. Da sind die Leute verunsichert, soll ich das wirklich machen lassen? Was ist, wenn ich danach nicht mehr laufen kann? Und dann spricht man mit Verwandten, mit Freunden und dann sagt man, nee, der Onkel so und so hat ja auch schon eine Hüft-OP und der konnte schon drei Wochen wieder vom Bett aufspringen und es ist alles wunderbar. Und dann wird man dadurch durch das soziale Umfeld dazu gebracht, seine Position noch mal zu überdenken und dann zum Beispiel eine Hüft-OP zu machen oder sich ein Hörgerät anzuschaffen. Genauso wird das bei einem ganz großen Teil der Bevölkerung, auch bei den Impfungen laufen. Sie werden sehen, ach ja, der hat es aber gut vertragen und mein Nachbar auch. Der hat auch gesagt, das sei gar kein Problem. Also lass ich das auch machen. Das sind die wahren Influencer, wenn man so möchte. Und die machen das alles unentgeltlich. Deswegen ist das eine vollkommen hirnrissige Kampagne, die da gestartet wurde.
Ja, vor allem Uschi Glas, als ich deinen Tüt gestern aufgriff und weiterverteilte, war die erste Reaktion. Sie lebt noch und das war auch ungefähr mein Tenor. Es ist nur noch 100-Jährige, selbst bei DSDS, bei RTL wird ja Dieter Bohlen, der 100-Jährige, gegen Thomas Gottschalk, den 110-Jährigen ausgetauscht. Also nicht mal das Privatfernsehen kann sich noch dagegen verwahren, obwohl man Dieter Bohlen eigentlich rausgeschmissen hat, um mal wieder Richtung Realität abzubiegen. Aber nein, es gab auch da eine Brückenlösung. Man hat noch mal ganz alte Register gegriffen. Du kennst Ines Schwertner ein bisschen besser. Ich kenne sie nur auf Twitter. Sie hat gestern einen sehr lustigen Tweet geschrieben. Der ganze Spaß darin steckt einfach nur in ganz subtiler Wortwahl. Sie hat geschrieben, ich habe schon mal aus Spaß meinen Impfausweis gesucht. Und was wollt ihr mit den alten gelben Lappen? Das ist einfach der Weltallerschönste. Und sie hat den von der DDR, den roten, der noch sozusagen reingestanzt wurde, der Hammer und Zirkel und aus Spaß, das ist genau der Tenor. Ich habe aus Spaß mal noch meinen, denn alles, was wir hier über Impfung bisher gesagt haben, das ist ja für uns Zuschauersport. Wir sitzen ja nicht mal mit im Stadion, wo die Impfkampagne ist, sondern wir sind verbannt irgendwohin. Und Karl Lauterbach redet sich den Mundfusslich, eine Erstimpfungskampagne loszutreten, die uns dann wenigstens mal im Juli, August eine Chance gibt, auch mal eine Impfung zu bekommen. Aber wer weiß, davon sind wir noch weit weg.
Und es wird zu wenig thematisiert, wenn es um die Kritik geht. Das finde ich jetzt auch wieder so erstaunlich an diesem Video von Rezo. Es gibt ja jetzt so eine Zerstörung der Corona-Politik von ihm. Da ist erst mal zu sagen, das ist nicht ein YouTube-Video, ein originäres, sondern es ist nur der Supercut aus einem Twitch-Stream und dort ereifert sich Rezo sehr wütend, polemisch über die Corona-Politik der Ministerpräsidenten. Merkel wird in diesen zwölf Minuten interessanterweise nicht einmal erlebt. Also da muss man auch mal fragen, wie tief sitzt die Schere im Kopf. Und auch, dass das ganze Problem bei den Impfungen primär liegt, wird nicht gesagt. Und das immer nur gesagt hat, hört auf die Wissenschaft. Das kann man auch mal bei den Impfungen sagen. Genauso auch immer dieses, ja die Ministerpräsidenten, die sorgen jetzt dafür, dass die Menschen sterben. Die sind schuld daran. Was schützt am besten vor Tod? Eine Impfung. Es ist einfach so. Das ist das Entscheidende. Deswegen kann man das sehr schnell mal umdrehen und fragen, ob nicht hauptschuldig an Corona-Toten jene sind, die es verpasst haben, genügend Impfstoffe zu besorgen, auszubauen, all das.
Und ich finde, jeder, der sich im hohen Alter drauf verlässt, noch ein bisschen Zeit zum Zweifeln zu haben, weil die Bundesregierung für ihn ja schon im Archiv den Impfstoff hat und da auch stehen lässt, der macht sich auch mitschuldig, ehrlich gesagt. Denn umso langsamer wandert diese Impfung durch die Generationen. Zu mir zum Beispiel. Deswegen würde ich sagen, jeder bekommt ein Impfangebot. Und wenn es ausgeschlagen ist, ist es erst mal ausgeschlagen. Man kann ja dann im August, wenn man fertig ist mit Nachdenken, immer noch sich seine Impfung abholen. Na ja, aber wie gesagt, Brückentechnologie. Für wen wird der Lockdown nicht gelten? Wir haben ja in der Märzausgabe angeschnitten, dass es hier soziale Verwerfung gibt beim Thema Corona, dass es vielleicht eine Unterschichtenkrankheit ist. Und stellt sich raus, der Spiegel gestern Morgen, am 6. April, 7.45 Uhr. Überschrift, wo die Pandemie besonders hart zuschlägt, unterzeile viele Menschen wenig Raum, hoher Migrationsanteil. Soziale Brennpunkte entwickeln sich zu Corona-EPI-Zentren. Besonders deutlich wird das in Berlin, Neukölln. Da hat sich also eine Journalistin, Katrin Elger, mal drangesetzt und dem Spiegel das unterbreitet. Es ist ein Spiegel-Plus-Text, den ich also nicht gelesen habe. Ich hab jetzt nur vorgetragen, was für alle sichtbar ist. In der Hoffnung, dass dieses Thema bis zum Wochenende bleibt und dann auch in der regulären Spiegel-Ausgabe zu finden ist. Und heute Morgen wurde noch mal ein Nachgeschoben von Florian Diekmann und Alexander Preker. Zitat, meine Gesundheit zählt nicht. Auch ein Spiegel-Plus-Text. Millionen Beschäftigte in Deutschland haben Angst, sich mit Corona zu infizieren, weil ihr Betrieb den Arbeitsschutz missachtet. Fünf Betroffene erzählen von ihrem Berufsalltag ohne Homeoffice und Hygienemaßnahmen. Die beiden Fälle leben in Berlin-Neukölln und leben oder arbeiten. Hier ist es im Falle des Textes eine Baustelle, die gezeigt wird, wie Schulter an Schulter schwere Stahlplatten getragen werden. Da wissen wir, da kann der Lockdown noch so hart sein. Also in Berlin-Neukölln wird sich das Leben nicht plötzlich wandeln und auf den Baustellen wird auch weiter gebaut werden. Da lässt sich niemand was nehmen. Denn, dritter Text, den ich jetzt noch kurz nennen möchte, ist auch von heute, siebter, vierter, 10.38 Uhr, nicht mal eine Stunde alt. CDU-Wirtschaftsrat distanziert sich von Laschet's Lockdown-Forderung. Blablabla, also in deren Sicht. Es sind die alten Kräfte hier am Werk.
Es sind die alten Kräfte und ganz interessant fand ich, dass mir ein Arzt geschrieben hat, das sei so nicht richtig, mit Karl Lauterbach. Und im Prinzip hat die E-Mail dann mir gezeigt, es ist eigentlich noch viel schlimmer. Karl Lauterbach hat sich sehr wohl früher um diese sozialen Fragen in der Gesundheit gekümmert, hat auch ein Buch geschrieben über Zwei-Klassen-Medizin. Umso furchtbarer, dass er es jetzt nicht zum großen Thema macht, also zu zeigen, Corona und Armut, wie eng das miteinander verknüpft ist. Das ist also ein Versäumnis und ich würde da auch einfach mal sagen, wir haben im September eine Wahl, wir sind jetzt im Wahlkampf. Man muss jetzt nicht länger der Pressersprecher der Bundesregierung sein, sondern kann jetzt auch mal parteipolitisch ein bisschen wirken, wenn man noch ein leises Interesse daran hat. Man muss sagen, da kommt generell nicht viel, also auch gut von Kevin Kühnert, da erwarten wir beide, glaube ich, gar nichts mehr, außer dass er irgendwann eine tolle Karriere macht. Aber es ist schon ein Trauerspiel und die Selbstgerechten, wie Luisa Neubauer oder so, die dann noch Bundeslockdown twittern und selbst das noch aus dem ICE raus twittern, siehst du, dann wird die Insta-Story eröffnet. Da fragt man sich schon, wie sehr kann man eigentlich glauben, dass man nicht zur Gesellschaft gehört oder dass einem Sonderrechte zugestehen? Man kann es ja so sehen, aber dann kann man das nicht noch von anderen einfordern. Und das ist einfach sehr traurig und wird auch die Verwerfungen immer größer machen. Also das ist ja klar, dass man da dann eigentlich mit dem Rücken zur Wand steht. Und ich bin auch mal sehr gespannt, das ist etwas, was Mick angesprochen hat bei dir im letzten Fernsehpodcast, inwieweit das Spielchen so aufgeht, dass man zeigt, der Laschet steht mit dem Rücken an der Wand. Wir wissen, dass wenn alle Etablierten sagen, der Laschet, der ist so doof und so weiter, dass dann eine große Solidarisierungswelle stattfinden kann. Und Mick sagte ja, dass ihm Laschet zum ersten Mal gefallen hat, weil er mal so authentisch aus sich heraus was gesagt hat und man auch seine Unbeholfenheit bemerkt hat. Und das ist ja ein Effekt, den erleben wir ja bei, haben wir erlebt bei Trump ganz stark. Und insofern frage ich mich, ob das nicht nochmal kippen kann, dass man sagt, ach ja, das sind die Selbstgerechten, die alle über Laschet lachen, die lachen aber auch über mich. Und deswegen solidarisiere ich mich eher mit Laschet und kann damit was anfangen. Nur mal so eine leise Befürchtung. Also nicht, dass ich das hoffe, weil ich wirklich nicht einen Kanzler Laschet möchte. Aber das steht zu befürchten.
Das stimmt. Ich würde auch sagen, Laschet, das hat man, also wir haben ja im Fernsehpodcast sehr tief reingeschaut in jede einzelne Regung seines Gesichtes die Woche über, die so im Fernsehen versendet wurde. Und Laschet hat noch Pfeile im Köcher. Das ist ganz erstaunlich, denn wenn man sich die Corona-Lagen mal anschaut und wirklich sachlich die Bundesländer miteinander vergleicht, steht Bayern ganz hinten. Nirgendwo läuft es so schlecht mit Corona wie in Bayern. Und da hängt so ein König drüber, der hier die ganze Zeit dann den Lockdown auch nochmal an sich reißt als Idee. Aber von dem dokumentiert ist, wie er ein Jahr lang darauf setzt, die Merkel soll entscheiden, der Bund soll das machen, ich will diese Entscheidung nicht treffen, ich will hier für nicht im Feuer stehen, wir brauchen eine bundeseinheitliche Lösung, wir müssen in der nächsten Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz alle gemeinsam und so weiter und so fort. Obwohl man in Bayern auch einfach mal hätte entscheiden können, wenn man da einen Lockdown braucht, macht man Lockdown. Nur wir sehen ja, wir sehen ja am Wirtschaftsrat der CDU, es gibt Oppositionen gegen Lockdown. Lockdown heißt nämlich Standortnachteil. Und das kann Bayern ja gar nicht haben, nachdem man sich selbst bei der Grundsteuer eigene Zuständigkeiten rausgearbeitet hat, sollen die beim Lockdown plötzlich gar nicht gelten. Also da, wo die Wirtschaft mal gelockt down wird, da möchte Bayern gar nicht alleine stehen gerne, sondern da hofft man einfach, wenn dann schon, dann machen ja wohl alle mit. Auch die in Schleswig-Holstein machte sich noch lustig über Daniel Günther. Daniel Günther war ja bisher nicht gut zu sprechen auf Friedrich Merz. Dieser Hass, also in dem Fall war es wirklich Hass, diese Ablehnung schwappt jetzt langsam über auf Söder. Also in der Ansicht, Laschet ist noch gar nicht so schlecht positioniert, wie man immer glaubt. Und die Zeit, Laschet möchte ja schnell entscheiden. Jetzt sind ja die 50 Tage zwischen Ostern und Pfingsten. Söder möchte gerne lange entscheiden, damit die Stimmung noch ein bisschen in seine Richtung kippt. Aber Ralf Brinkhaus verlangt heute, und das war auch der Spiegelaufmacher den ganzen Morgen, Brinkhaus verlangt rasche Entscheidungen. Der K-Frager, der doch gleich schreiben können, lasst uns für Laschet jetzt optieren. In deren Sicht wird das noch ein ganz interessanter Showdown, das Söder da irgendwie ist, nicht gesetzt. Und ich will noch mal anfügen, ich war ja über Ostern verreist. Allerdings, zumindest die weiblichen Mitglieder dieser Familie sind komplett geimpft. Und in NRW ist es wirklich krass. In NRW fahren die Leute mit Maskenauto. Und sie treffen sich auch in Gärten und haben Masken auf. Das habe ich hier in Hessen noch nie gesehen. Es gibt Maskenpflicht auf Spielplätzen, an die sich alle halten. Also für die Erwachsenen gilt das. Und das ist wirklich krass. Also die Disziplin in NRW ist erstaunlich hoch.
Ich habe es schon beobachtet im Sommer in Düsseldorf. Ich war erstaunt. Ich bin in Koblenz weggefahren. Hier liefen alle dicht aneinander vorbei. Niemand eine Maske wirklich. Nirgends. Das war ja ganz niedrig. In Düsseldorf trugen ohne, dass man das gesagt hat, fast alle wie selbstverständlich Masken.
Ja, und es nervt mich hier in Hessen auch, dass es die Disziplin hier nicht gibt. Was für mich bedeutet, ich bin da im Ratschlag gefolgt und hab mir jetzt die 3M-Masken gekauft, die mit Zweifaltungen über Mund und Nase ein bisschen perfekter, gut, besser sitzen sollen. Und da ich auch mal ins Fitnessstudio gehen will, dort gilt die Regel, am Gerät darf das Ding abgesetzt werden. Was heißt, da läuft einfach jeder ohne Maske rum. Das ist also wirklich unglaubliche Zustände. Und ich werde da dann ab morgen mit meiner 3M-Maske sein und hoffentlich Vorbildwirkung haben. Denn wenn die im Fitnessstudio das wieder zugemacht haben, sind alle selber schuld, die ins Fitnessstudio gehen. Das muss man einfach sagen.
Und die haben auch bei euch, das wusste ich gar nicht.
Ja, in Hessen ist irgendwie, ich weiß auch nicht genau. Entweder haben wir hier Glück oder was weiß ich, dass die nicht ganz so explodieren, die Zahlen. Aber Corona-Maßnahmen laufen hier in Hessen nicht besonders gut. Ich war jedenfalls sehr beeindruckt von unseren Mitbürgern in NRW. In deren Sicht kann man sich eine Scheibe abschneiden. Ich weiß nicht, wie es in Bayern ist. Aber ich hab gelesen, in Bayern gab es ja gestern, da haben sich viele drüber lustig gemacht. Der Zoo hat wieder aufgemacht und man durfte auch wieder einkaufen gehen. Denn über Ostern ist ja die Inzidenz gefallen auf unter 100. Obwohl alle wissen, das ist der müsterliche Meldeverzug.
Aber sehr amüsant. Sollte Lahrstadtkanzler werden, werde ich mich also zur Verfügung stellen als Freiwilliger und ihm einmal erklären, wie man eine Krawatte bindet. Ich dachte, das kann er durch seinen Influenzsohn und durch die Kontakte zu fahren lagen, aber er kriegt es nicht hin. Also einfach mal, lieber Herr Lahrstadt, doppelter Winzer ist das Beste. Gerade wenn man ein bisschen mit dem Hals, also ich sag's mal so, ist es vorteilhafter, nicht da so einen komischen dünnen Strick runterzudrehen.
Ja, aber guck mal, du bindest halt deine Krawatte, wie man sie in Rheinland-Pfalz bildet.
Ach, meinst du, da gibt es im Pott... Also ich würde sagen, ich habe auch wirklich einen Pott, aber nicht in Düsseldorf, da weiß man schon, wie man eine Krawatte bindet. Und da isst Herr Laschet ja hin und wieder mal.
Das stimmt, denn manchmal ist er ja auch noch arbeiten. Er ist ja berufstätig, das wird er vielleicht vergessen bei diesem ganzen Wahlkampf-Videos. Gut, wir gehen jetzt in den Salon, wir lesen Bücher über die Zukunft der Arbeit und die Gegenwart der Tristesse.
Julia Friedrichs ist ja sehr eingefangen.
Dann hab ich mir auf Twitter Ratschläge geholt, welche RNA-Texte kann man denn lesen, wo man mal ein bisschen informiert wird. Es gibt schon große journalistische, The Atlantic und so weiter, die hab ich ausgespart. Es gibt Pressemitteilungen, wissenschaftliche Texte. Da gehen wir ein bisschen rein, um mal wirklich, was ist der Kern, uns zu informieren. Beim Spiegel wurden hundert Versäumnisse bei der Klimapolitik aufgelistet der Bundesregierung. Es ist nicht alles, also es ist alles wie Corona, sagt man mal so. Jedes Politikfeld wird wie Corona Politik gemacht. Und zum Ende werden wir nochmal diesen großen, Janet Yellen, Mario Draghi, was müssen die jetzt eigentlich machen von Adam Toos? Nochmal auf eine Pointe hin lesen. Das wäre das Programm von meiner Seite.
Von meiner Seite aus kommen noch zwei Bücher dazu. Einmal Kapital und nein Ressentiment und nein, noch mal richtig jetzt. Also von Josef Vogel Kapital und Ressentiment. Josef Vogel ist eigentlich Literaturwissenschaftler, setzt sich hier aber mit dem digitalen Kapitalismus, mit der Aufmerksamkeitsökonomie, mit den Finanzmärkten und mit der Meinungsbildung auf den sozialen Medien auseinander, verbindet das alles und bringt noch mal eine große Analyse dessen, was wir jetzt so in den vergangenen Jahren erlebt haben, versucht haben, so particular zu verstehen. Und ich finde das sehr geglückt. Es ist kein ganz leichtes Buch, aber doch eines, das sehr, sehr wert ist, gelesen zu werden. Dann noch ein Buch von Adriano Manino, ein Buch, das mich beglückt hat, obwohl das Thema gar nicht beglückend ist. Es geht um Triage. Es hat den provokanten Titel Wen rette ich und wenn ja, wie viele? Und dieses Buch ist ganz großartig, weil man wunderbar lernen kann, wie klar Ethik, Ethik sein kann, ethisches Denken sein kann. Es ist ein bisschen und das meine ich jetzt gar nicht so funktionalistisch Gehirnjogging, wenn man das liest, dass man einfach mal die verschiedenen Möglichkeiten durchspielt, wen rette ich und wenn ja, wie viele? Und es wird hier auch mal deutlich gemacht, warum das Alter sehr wohl das Lebensalter ein Kriterium sein kann bei der Rettung. Und das ist hier nicht einfach nur darum geht, wir wiegen Menschenleben aus und und und gegeneinander spielen wir sie aus. Das ist ein Buch, das ja eine schöne Klarheit reinbringt. Eigentlich das, was man zu diesem Thema gern mal in Talkshows erlebt hätte. Stattdessen haben sie immer so weggeduckt oder haben einfach nur so vom Ethikrat da so ein paar verwirrende Dinge von sich gegeben.
Ich warte ja immer noch auf einen klugen, auf den ersten klugen Beitrag des Ethikrats in Deutschland.
Ja, hier ist er geschrieben, den könnte man so übernehmen, also ein tolles Buch. Und dann gucken wir noch auf Instagram Reels. Wir gucken noch mal ganz kurz auf Sneaker, in denen menschliches Blut ist und wir schauen uns noch die Rating Agenturen kurz an.
Okay, sehr gut, volles Programm. Na dann gehen wir jetzt auf den Salon und wir hoffen, dass ihr uns jetzt zahlreich folgt. Denn dieser Podcast, auch der große, die Monatsausgabe, ist nur möglich, weil es hier Salonisten gibt, die uns dabei helfen. Sehr gut, also bis gleich.
Bis gleich.